the Joe Rogan experience spiritualities
a weird word what does that mean it's a
very taboo word is a very abused word is
abused they're sure it's I'm not really
just for them spiritual like that kind
of [ __ ] yeah yes where it gets weird
yeah I don't like that at all
you know when I speak about spirituality
I'm speaking about something that really
can't be put into words its unfathomable
you know our language isn't designed to
talk about this stuff mm-hmm you know
when we look at oh well a new speak
there's certain words that don't exist
for this stuff you have to use a ancient
language and even ancient language you
tried translating to English it's like
we don't have a word for this yeah how
do you know you're seeing seeing like
ancient Hebrew when they try to
translate things right ancient Hebrew at
all the numbers were actually all the
letters were either actually numbers as
well correct
correct yeah do you know when you talk
about halos that the original halo was a
mushroom cap no what
yeah a mushroom cap yeah oh okay I got
you the original halo
mm-hmm was well there's a book called
the sacred mushroom in the cross it's by
John Marco Allegro and he was a biblical
scholar that was one of the guys that
was assigned to decipher the Dead Sea
Scrolls which is the oldest version of
the Bible yes the only one I think that
they've ever found it's written in
Aramaic and it was found in Qumran and
these clay clay tap these clay jars and
it's there that's all made unwritten on
animal skins to decipher it they
actually had to run DNA tests on the
animal skins to figure out which skins
belong to which animal so they could put
all the stuff together to figure out all
this all these pieces were a part of
this one scroll yeah well this guy John
Marco Allegro studied it for 14 years
and it was his conclusion after he was
done that the entire Christian religion
was a giant misunderstanding what it was
originally about was the consumption of
psychedelic mushrooms and fertility
rituals mm-hmm and they started doing
all of these these different scholars
who studied ancient art and ancient
religious art they started finding these
this mushroom iconography and all this
ancient artwork
and one of the things they notice is
that the bottom of a mushroom you take
particularly the Amanita muscaria
mushroom which is the one that they
connect to to the Christian religion
look at the bottom of it and see what it
looks like with all those lines now look
at that that was the original halo okay
if you see that picture about with Jesus
with the halo around his head
the halo was essentially the bottom of a
mushroom cap and the idea they believed
was that these people were the ones that
were consuming the psychedelic mushroom
so they had this great wisdom and this
connection to God mmm that's what they
thought mana was that's as they thought
these psychedelic mushrooms were the
flesh of God I like that yeah and so
that when you have these ancient
religions that were possibly based on
the consumptions of these psychedelic
mushrooms all that stuff has kind of
been lost in the translation over years
and years and years and then even the
visualization of the halos change yeah
and there's there's also some really
crazy ones of naked people dancing in
ecstasy surrounded by this translucent
mushroom image so the idea that they
were in these mushroom induced euphoric
States and that they were dancing around
these all these religious depictions
yeah very interesting because if you
think about ancient religions right
no no science they had no idea what
shape the world was they didn't know
anything but they did know if you found
these mushrooms and you took a meat rip
your [ __ ] balls off right he would
have this incredible experience and they
thought that was God you know there was
that was their connection to God mm-hmm
you know so there's that's interesting
yeah it's a great book and the Catholic
Church actually bought it out and they
they they got rid of it and then you
could only buy used copies of it but
then it was republished recently over
the last few years someone got the
rights to it mm-hmm
yeah it's intense stuff yeah I like that
conversation yeah that's sexy yeah you
know anything that goes away from the
norm I think is real sexy I needs to n
need to be taught and needs to be talked
about
[Applause]